let k equals 6 so that f of x is equal
to 1 over x squared minus 6x
find the partial fraction decomposition
for the function f
find the integral of f of x dx
and so let's first think about the
partial fraction decomposition for the
function f
so f of x
i could rewrite it where i factor the
denominator if i factor out an x i get x
times
x minus 6
and so i can rewrite this as and this is
where i'm going to decompose it into
partial fractions
a
over
a over x
plus
b
over
x minus 6.
and if i actually had to add these two i
would try to find a common denominator
and the the best common denominator is
just take the product of these two
expressions so i can multiply the
numerator and the denominator of this
first term by x minus 6
x minus 6 and then the numerator and
denominator of the second term i can
multiply it by the denominator of the
other one so times x
and times x and so that would give us
let's see if i distribute the a it would
give us a
x
minus 6 a
plus b x
plus b x over
over
x times x minus 6
x times x minus six if this looks
completely foreign to you i encourage
you to watch the videos on khan academy
on partial frac fraction decomposition
all right so let's see if we can
so what we want to do is we want to
solve for the a's and
we want to solve for the a's and the b's
and so let's see
if
we see that these have to add up to 1
over x times x minus 6.
so these have to add up i'm just going
back to this these have to add up the
numerator so it has to add up to 1 over
x times x minus 6 and so this numerator
has to add up to 1.
so what we can see is is that the x
terms right over here must cancel out
since we have no x terms here so we have
a x
plus b x must be equal to zero or you
could say
well that means that a plus b
is equal to zero so we took care of that
term and that term and then we know that
this must be the constant term that adds
up to one or that is equal to one and so
we also know that negative six a is
equal to one or a is equal to divide
both sides by negative 6
negative 1 6
and then if a is negative 1 6 well b is
going to be the negative of that
we have negative 1 6 plus b i'm just
substituting a back into that equation
need to be equal to 0 and so add 1 6 to
both sides you get b is equal to 1 6. so
i can decompose f of x
i can decompose f of x as being equal to
a over x
so that's negative 1 6
over x i just write it that way i could
write it as negative
1 over 6 x or something like that but
i'll just write it like this just to be
clear that this was our a plus b
which is 1 6
over
x minus 6
x
minus 6. so that right over there that's
the partial fraction decomposition for
our function f and if i want to evaluate
the integral
so the integral of f of x the indefinite
integral
well that's where this partial fraction
decomposition is going to be valuable
that's going to be the indefinite
integral of
negative 1 6 over x
plus positive 1 6
over x minus 6
and then we have
dx
well what's the anti-derivative of this
right over here well the anti-derivative
of 1 over x is the natural log of the
absolute value of x and so we can just
say this is going to be negative 1 6
times the natural log of the absolute
value of x that's the anti-derivative of
this part
and then plus 1 6
plus 1 6. you could do u substitution
but you could just say hey look the
derivative of this bottom part x minus
6. that's just 1. and so you could say
that okay i have that derivative laying
around and so this is so i can just take
the antiderivative with respect to that
and so that's going to be 1 6 times the
natural log
of the absolute value of x minus 6
and then i have
and then i have plus c don't forget this
is an indefinite integral over here and
then you're done and you see that that
partial fraction decomposition was
actually quite useful so they were
helping us how to figure out how to
figure out this you didn't just have to
have that insight they're like okay how
do i evaluate this anti-derivative well
they're telling us to use partial
fraction decomposition